what happens when a father-to-be finds
out that he was born a sextuplet and you
make a show out of it in every single
person in the families played by Marlon
Wayans
it's called sextuplets on Netflix starts
framing front us streaming Friday August
16th good to see you mom good to see you
as well
you always look the same age is that
right yes old it's like never look young
but you don't look old you're hovering
around 55 which is like Donna you he
looked like 94 holy still that's the
same Donna Donna what she looks exactly
the same
merv griffin exactly the same morgan
freeman exactly the same by the way all
three of those people that you mentioned
hugely successful exactly Rich Eisen
extremely successful appreciation cup
that I stole from your sick because you
don't get him out of swag no cheaper you
sir drink up this stolen cup every
morning the number of times that we say
what happened to the Rich Eisen show mug
that was on the corner of the desk with
Marlon Wayans showed up and we're like
wow okay well I mean I saw and then I
look at your Instagram account and there
it is well I'll be real I'm gonna steal
this one too tonight I want them
drinking out the same cup in the morning
because that's cute couple coot
one of my look I don't usually like to
talk about myself but since you started
the interview this way I'm gonna have to
go for it how many segments we got
before we do this one big large phone I
don't want to waste a moment now um sure
is that I maintain that's what I do for
I'm one of my great attributes on a
maintainer I maintain you've maintained
taken 55 she was like
50 though well that's a good thing you
have five years more 55 before your 60
it all makes it and I like how you made
yourself like an action star in this run
you do not run like this
I've seen your feet they're like pigeon
toe and bowlegged your feet look like
Antonio Browns feet can we turn around
feet please his feet has been injured
since the Steelers his feet have always
only feet I've seen uglier than his feet
is like my dad's feet and that's saying
some like Antonio Brown sweet if you if
he was to put his footprint in the snow
I would have thought it was an alien is
the ugliest sole fetus so ugly LeBrons
feet is like how your dad's feet though
fur fur uh sir a post pattern can he can
he run it cuz at this point in time he
might be my dad I can't even walk he
just slips he has a bunion on the baby
toe that's weird what no that's like
reengineering like I don't know if it's
pus or cheese and if you cuz they all
gathered together like like this and if
you lift one room starts thinking I'm
like I don't know what I think I don't
know Brown has the same infection like
guys you're at your dad yeah I think
they both have herpes on their feet six
weeks injury he's up to start running on
his hands and catching with them as well
have you done trial if you ever done
trial I can't cry okay so would you want
to buy a hat Antonio Brown's feet well
you know I always think that I don't
need shoes either
you have you ever thought in a million
years to go into a cryo machine without
any socks or slippers on or just going
barefoot no I go in cryo machine and I'm
like where's my jacket
what do you mean this freezing cold
water cold for what for Tex I'll just be
inflamed I don't need to do this I try
to get my son my son plays ball yes and
I try to get him to do cryo he did it
one time and he was in 15 seconds he was
like he gave me like a timeout like so I
think we have a Marlon Wayans here on
the richezza Joe I think we have footage
of your son playing right now how old is
your son my son is 17 years old okay and
he's an amazing ballplayer he's like
everything I wished I was industries man
that splash I swear the only reason why
plays like this is because of my skill
set and above the room and six-man low
oh oh look at this Oh get him [ __ ] son
oh oh the steal and the bucket look at
that and he's pretty he's so
good-looking I named him after my
brother because I'm not that
good-looking I can't maintain that but
nobody would believe he was my junior
look at this move oh come on give it
your sweetness that's sweetness right
there that is nice you see that that's
that's came from me yeah that is
literally imagine if you're your ex and
wise could do that like I would be very
very happy I'm so proud like am i of my
exes my ex is in USC like my golden ads
is doing work now do you do a LeBron
when he scores to jump on on the court
LeBron I'm like LeBron
too passive I've been kicked out of mini
games I got kicked out of my how about
this I got kicked out of my son's game
at my daughter's school well you gotta
walk me through this now huh but you
have to walk me through the details of
that no because the ref wasn't calling
fast cuz my son is at least five ten
right but he's strong he always goes in
the middle
but these refs they don't call it when
the little guy goes in and I'm like yo
he's getting smash I'm like what do you
got to do here's a dagger and his neck
somebody he has a bullet wound call the
foul cuz this is my son
I made them if you're not gonna call the
foul sure I'm gonna get upset because if
he gets a and then my son's lips started
bleeding so I was like all right so now
because you didn't call a foul I got to
fight you because that's my son and your
responsibility with this whistle to call
the foul and I don't think me
threatening them tall telling me it was
a one-eyed Cyclops was and a couple of
f-bombs was good enough to the gate they
ejected you oh they kicked me out they
kicked me out three games and then at a
point now I just sit sit you see here's
the thing before I go to games you don't
hit my mom Angela always asked me to my
kids mom she goes did you have coffee
and I go no they know they give me
coffee I'm gonna be super hyped so no
coffee before games and Shawn is amazing
check out his real - on my youtube and
it's on my my Twitter at Marlins the
college coaches hallo you got a great
kid you never got in trouble yeah I get
him on a team I mean why wouldn't they
want you to be at their games I don't
know I'm trying to tell them let me get
kicked out of my son's game at your
school oh my god the Lavar ball of
comedy more lands here on the Richard
show here what do you think about what's
going on here in Los Angeles with the
actual the actual NBA's I'm just happy
that basketballs basketball again I got
tired of watching what's that movie
would look with a Jordan Space Jam okay
the Warriors was just they were the
Monstars you can't defeat that team I'm
glad KD went to Brooklyn with DeAndre
and Kyrie I'm from New York I finally
got a reason to love a New York team now
I'm happy LeBron got a ad and I'm but
I'm happy that like what's his name with
the with the prison come on come on
why yes I'm glad that while he does look
like you got a prison cornrows cuz
they're not new and fresh they look like
I just ran for him braiding them like
six years ago and he kept I'm gonna keep
these braids in for you boo
I mean it's not like dope like you kid
schema see scalp now I just wanted for
the record that I knew you were talking
about Kawhi before you determine whose
hair about that except for Kawhi I'm
gonna get a letter or at the game but
I'm happy that basketball is competitive
again and me as of a sports fan that
makes me happy
right here in Li - yes Paul George and
you know that and the NBA knows it too
right the Lakers and Clippers are
opening up against each other and then
they're they're playing in a sense
they're happy for both franchises see
here's the thing everybody knows this
I'm and it's not it's not intentional
okay I've been a Laker hater okay mm-hmm
and I love Jeanne bush I love what her
dad did would seem I love I love the
colors purple and yellow I love I love I
love most of the fans yes I am a Laker
hater because my friends came from New
York hmm and then they joined the Lakers
just because they were good and so I
feel it's my duty to be a Laker hater
because when they lose and I watch them
cry it makes me feel good and then
there's like three or four guys that
been Laker fans since they was little
did I hate who are my friends and I like
inviting them over my house when I know
there's a team that's gonna beat them
just so I could see them be mad and cry
nothing better than to watch grown men
cry about something they're not getting
paid for you taking the bus why are you
worried about what they got excuse me
we before we let you go Marlon Wayans
let's talk about sextuplets yes Netflix
Friday August 16th you play six people
that's all the hell that's you seen me
talk I'll just talk for 35 minutes I
know without a break this is this yeah
but you you either you're yourself here
you don't you don't get into makeup and
I have 62 personalities you want to
interview them all you got five days
here's the thing like it's very hard to
do as I'm talking to sometimes I'm
talking to a double right person so most
of the time I'm talking to a stick with
a
a pink piece of tape on it and for your
eyes side yeah because really I'm
talking to me most of the scenes like
those for people yeah all mean to me and
I have to film the scene four different
times and remember what I did that's
each one of those things cuz there's not
like there's a moderate or anything I
have to remember what I did the day
before and the timing of it and I've an
earwig in my ear so I can hear me but
the reality is I'm improvising and doing
stuff as each character differently it's
it is the craziest thing I ever did my
best work I need y'all to see this
August 16th
14th 60/60 Netflix on Netflix it's a
blast you got to see it it's something
is not like we use the technology from
like the Avengers to make this happen so
it's like the Klumps meet the Avengers
it's amazing it's you're amazing in it
Molly Shannon and Mikey Michael Ian
Black
also in it so you're some funny pain
free [ __ ] web is amazing in the movie
and before I'd go cuz I sound like you
about to play music like the hostages
and kick me off oh I got some dates I
want to tell you how August 23rd I'm be
doing stand-up comedy at Tommy T's in
Pleasanton California September 6
through 8 I'm at the funny bone in
Columbus Ohio
September 14th I'm at the MGM National
Harbor theater and Washington DC one
show and chocolate City get your tickets
hurry up is filling up fast September
2019 through the twenty-first I'm gonna
comment at the concert in Rochester New
York
October 25th through 27 Pittsburgh
improv November 22nd through 24
punchline turn-taking lastly December
20th through 22nd I'm at the improv and
Irvine get your tickets and September 14
MGM national Harper theatre that's gonna
be a big show
come see me I'm doing I'm a talk about
Antonio Browns feet for at least
singing I need their own show you may
and disorders Deion Deion Sanders
frequently watches the show in his tub
his feet yes he does
lets me know he doesn't know what is
about football players in their feet
well I mean he retired he didn't have
any problems he retired cos visto a turf
toe like literally it is is his middle
toe just is on top of this dike that's
all so he got my father's feet Wow
amazing yeah listen with my dad like and
it's messed up and I spicy okay the only
thing I want from my father cut my fat
dad is he's like 83 only I want for my
father
yeah when he passes like you wanna watch
or you won't like his favorite book
I want a PLAs of pairs of my father's
feet on my meds and that's where and I'm
sprinkle this snow yeah I'm just gonna
smell his feet and go I'm ready to start
my day it's very touching but very very
touching thanks for coming on please
that the mugs yours
oh man I don't have to steal it you've
given it to me it's yours to keep here's
the thing I like stealing it is what
really loves to drink it out of a stolen
cup woods thumbs up is way better come
back we'll have a replacement mug and
I'll look exactly the same okay thank
you
at Marlin wins on both our mystery at 55
still Friday August 16th stream it on
Netflix sextuplets very funny and and
then of course what's the website people
could go and find out what's on my
youtube all the way ins YouTube or check
my Instagram at marlon wayans college's
pick up a young great great student of
the game this kid is amazing Shawn
Wayans go check out his thing on NC
ANCSA and recruit him he's amazing kid
there you go so uh come back any time
thank you so much when we come back JJ
Watt will be here from the Houston
Texans don't hear no on the phone oh
don't get my groupie up and anything
JJ Watt on the show for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app